voilà ça commence à péter le matos on va
pas y arriver
comment ça va vous allez bien tout va
bien aujourd'hui bon alors c'est un
sujet dont je voulais vous en parlait il
ya longtemps j'ai pris beaucoup de temps
pour vous en parler
et enfin je vous en reparle aujourd'hui
on parle ici des airpod max d'apple
c'est le premier casque d'apple dans
l'état alors apple a racheté be ça
quelques années donc vous retrouver des
casques sont beats au catalogue d'apple
mais c'est la première fois qu'apple
nous sort qu as tu finis un casque
extrêmement premium un tarif assez
énorme très élevé il est à 629 euros
pour être extrêmement précis alors
qu'est ce qu'on a à 629 euros chez apple
est ce que apple a bien réussi sa copie
est ce qu'apple nous sommes un cas ce
qui est réellement premium est ce qui
vaut le coup est ce qu'il faut se
positionner alors après en face faut
regarder parce que la concurrence ya
plein de modèles notamment celui là que
j'ai utilisé pendant très très très très
très longtemps cwh melixon 3g est basée
sur le mix am3 parce que le mix n 4 est
une belle évolution du mix n3 mais bon
bah il révolutionne pas bien l'histoire
donc on va essayer de voir ça parce que
c'est vrai que là vous êtes quand même
très gros budget vous avez un casque
très atypique au niveau du design au
niveau de beaucoup de choses
on va essayer de comprendre on va
essayer de comprendre si apple se moque
pas de vous quels sont les promesses
c'est ce que fait ce casque est ce qu'il
ne fait pas ça fait un mois plus d'un
mois qui chante dans mes oreilles tous
les soirs la journée il m'accompagne
aussi de revoir tout de suite si apple
qu'à ses promesses avec son casque
airpod max
[Musique]
ça c'est une entrée en matière je compte
sur nous dès maintenant pour me laisse
un joli like dans cette vidéo les likes
vous savez ça sert au référencement donc
si on veut que la vidéo soit vue il faut
des jolies light et surtout dites moi
vous ce que vous en pensez à brûle
pourpoint sans qu'on n'ait plus loin sur
le sujet alors je sais que beaucoup de
personnes ont parlé il ya d'excellentes
vidéo sur internet qui vous parle de ce
casque lie notamment je vous invite à
aller voir s'ils voulaient vraiment
creuser creuser creuser creuser d'aller
voir la vidéo de mon pote pp garcia qui
est super hyper documenté qui va très
très loin j'ai regardé une grosse
demi-heure d' aventure et c'est
vachement intéressant donc aller jeter
un coup d'oeil à sa chère vallée ce coup
de grâce à sa vidéo sur ce produit là
mais avant toute chose dites moi vous
est-ce que vous pensez que ce casque
lavos et 629 euros est ce que vous
pourriez mettre 129 euros sur un casque
aussi intéressant soit il la diplomate
dès maintenant en bas en commentaire
alors que tout est rentré dans le vif du
sujet quand apple est arrivé en fin
d'année dernière avec son casque et je
pense qu'ils ont pris tout le monde de
court en nous au regard des nouveaux la
bonbonne nous sommes là dans l'univers
de lo'jo nous arrivons à qu'un cas ce
que nous annonçons comme étant un casque
haute fidélité
on va voir si c'est le cas ou pas on
arrive avec un tout nouvel valeurs et
surtout c'est un casque qui s'appelle
airpod malheur airpod je pense que ça
vous parle on connaît leur paul hodé
l'ère post pro donc là-dessus ce casque
a vraiment emmené laden dr paul jean
tout cas et c'est vachement intéressant
parce que on dit l'airpod max alors
montrera plus leur peau de max meilhan
est donc scellé et repose pour moi sont
deux petits écouteurs 1ère powder pas
donc on a deux heures pose là pour moi
j'ai un seul cas ce dont ces leur poste
mais pourtant galère poil un petit peu
les soirs c'est un peu compliqué mais en
tout cas ça montre laden on est dans la
del dr poste donc ça c'est déjà
intéressant
première chose ce cas ce que là il est
différent au niveau de la fabrication
déjà vous le voyez ne serait-ce qu ici
la radio plaques ont bien besoin d'un
petit peu là vous n'êtes pas une espèce
de tissus alors bon c'est ce qu'ils
appellent un tissu mesh et ce tissu mesh
en fait il a plusieurs intérêts le
premier intérêt du tissu mesh c'est que
c'est un tissu respirant ça c'est bien
vous direz c'est super je transpire ok
il respire on est pour moi là où il est
vraiment intéressant et là oui vraiment
très très différent des autres casques
et je vous le montre notamment au
travers du double dash 1103 c'est que
autant sur le double dash me dis que ça
me trouve à regarder ici des petits
lapins
vous avez tous systèmes de coûts signer
avec de la mousse à mémoire qui vient
épouser la forme de votre crâne mais
malgré pour me sentais un point de
pression ça je vous ai déjà dit lorsque
j'ai testé ce casque et c'est souvent un
truc qu'on retrouve sur cette typologie
de casque vous avez le fameux point de
pression et ce qui est super intéressant
et là où on voit qu'apple a vraiment
bien creuser sa copie et bien c'est
qu'en fait ici vous n'avez pas se
remettre de points de pression
ma belle chevelure ans n'est plus qu est
ce qui est blanc qu'est-ce qu'il n'est
pas qu'est ce qui est le cheveu qu'est
ce qui est le kiosque eh bien voyez ça
c'est super intéressant parce que ici là
c'est pas les arceaux qui viennent te
dire ma tête c'est le tissu
il vient vraiment épouser la forme de
mon crâne dans quel que soit votre crâne
quelle que soit la forme de votre crâne
eh bien voyez il vient l'épousé avec une
zone de contact qui est assez large et
ce qui fait en fait que vous avez du
confort tout le temps partout et ça
vient une fois de plus adapté à tout le
monde donc ça c'est à côté qui a peu
révolutionnaire dans cette idée là parce
qu'on sort de la souris gide sur lequel
on vient apporter un côté un peu
molletonné moelleux comment retrouver si
notamment chez sony avec son doublé à
celle mythique scène 3 mais c'est la
belle pose rapide bmx n 4 et c'est la
même chose avec beaucoup de caste du
marché ce qui n'est pas forcément une
critique en assez casse parce que je les
aime bien mais en tout cas ici apple
arrive avec une proposition qui est
vraiment différente
alors après je me demande comment est-ce
qu'il va vieillir parce que une fois que
vous avez transpirer parce qu'on
transpire tous pour un sou du sébum les
cheveux grèce dans le temps vous avez
beau vous les lavez vous avez bouquin
comme très très propre le moment les
cheveux sa graisse donc est-ce qu'en fin
de journée avec le gel et compagnie moi
je mets de la syrah tous avoir sondé ses
priorités je met les siens dès lors il
n'y a pas de petit livre je me lave les
cheveux je prends après tout mais malgré
tout est ce qu'on va pas se retrouver
avec un tissu qui va s'altérer qui à
devenir un peu moins clean dans le temps
ça j'en sais rien petit coup de produits
et ça ce n'est toi faut l'entretenir
comme tout de toute façon ça c'est le
premier point le deuxième point qui
m'intéresse c'est vraiment la finition
niveau des matériaux parce que vous avez
signification qui sont vraiment
différentes vous allez retrouver
notamment ici et on le voit tout une
structure qui en acier inoxydable est ce
qui différencie vraiment de certains cas
ce que vous allez retrouver définition
en plastique ce qui va aussi permettre
d'expliquer la différence de prix parce
que l'acier inoxydable coûtera plus cher
que plastiques
a contrario le casque est beaucoup
beaucoup plus lourd mais ce qui est
assez intéressant là dessus c'est qu'en
termes de confort on se rend pas compte
il a beau être très lourd une fois que
vous l'avez positionner là comme vous
avez le tissu qu'il ya répartir vraiment
cette zone de pression ça vous permet
d'absorber complètement la différence du
poids et ça je trouve ça vraiment
vraiment très très malin vous avez les
boîtiers en aluminium anodisé et puis
vous avez surtout ça là ce sont des
branches télescopique et ça les branches
télescopique je trouve ça aussi très
malin on pourrait se dire que cette jupe
en détail mais c'est vraiment là dessus
que vient de se faire justement une fois
de plus le tarif est l'expérience
globale
vous venez le positionner
selon vous votre taille votre forme la
forme de votre tête la taille de votre
tête un bref par rapport à votre crâne
et une fois que vous l'avez positionner
belle bouge pas trop mais surtout ça
vient vraiment permettre de venir le
bouger il vient se repositionner pour se
maintenir et se plaquer contre vos
oreilles sans que ça ne pose de problème
parce qu'ici vous avez des consignes et
avec de la mousse à mémoire de forme des
coussinets vous pouvez enlever une fois
de plus je pense qu'il ya une notion
effectivement d'entretien ici on va le
retrouver parce que vous avez ce petit
tissu pour trouver ce tissu mesh que
vous avez là que vous êtes à l'intérieur
mais en plus vous le dis ici là vous
avez une petite mousse à mémoire de
forme donc tout ça fait que vous avez un
casque qui est vraiment vraiment
extrêmement confortable vous le posez la
répartition est bonne il vient se caler
grâce à ce petit système voyez up et
vient se caler ce plaqué contre vos
oreilles vous n'êtes pas pollué par le
poids vous n'êtes pas embêtés par le
maintien il est là escale bien donc ça
déjà c'est un excellent point et toute
cette partie là de finition et de
confort change par rapport à ce qu'on
peut avoir sur dreamcast que j'adore moi
je l'utilisé wmx m3 pendant des heures
on voit vraiment que ce produit-là
respire davantage le premium que son
copain de chez sony à l'expérience audio
elle est assez intéressante ce qu'il
faut savoir ici c'est que vous êtes sur
un casque qui va être 100% numérique
vous n'allez pas emmener du son grâce à
une prise jack et s'il y en a pas c'est
tout de suite ce que j'ai vu lorsque je
les récupère elle se dit ah mince ici il
n'y a pas de prise jack
moi j'aime bien dans chez mon casque je
peux faire avec le whc xm3 voyez j'ai ma
prise jack
lorsque je voyage que je prends l'avion
est bien jeune et je m'écoute un film un
peu moins en ce moment où je me branche
pour écouter légalement j'aime bien je
maximiser l'expérience j'ai ce côté
analogique et la gelée pas donc là je
sors du 100% numérique mais ce qui est
super intéressant et si on veut en tout
cas le travail qu'a fait apple là dessus
c'est que on a une expérience numérique
qui est dingue on nous annonce des lots
de fidélité l'idée de la haute fidélité
on est vraiment sur du son analogique on
n'a pas cette idée numérique pour voir
qu'on a dû numérique ici et pas
l'analogique eh bien on peut dire que
peut-être qu apple a réinventé la notion
de haute fidélité pour vous créer ce
qu'on appellera un casse-cou de fidélité
numérique parce qu'on est vraiment sur
une qualité audio qui est aux piscines
qui est vraiment exceptionnel
j'ai des fichiers top dans mon iphone
j'ai les fichiers d'excellente qualité
j'ai réécouté j'ai redécouvert des
morceaux que je connais je peux aller
très bien et que j'écoute j'écoute
j'écoute du bhoutan boucle je suis
amoureux de musique il ya souvent des
morceaux phares que j'aime bien avait
coûté en revenir dessus de temps en
temps eh bien j'ai redécouvert d'autres
choses la première chose c'est de
sensations de spa sise à sion il me sens
a erré en février j'ai pas besoin d'être
sûr toutes écrit étriqué où je suis
enfermé c'est faux s'est ouvert ses
larges qu'un instrument il est là tient
pas le coup de cymbale à elle est bien à
lhassa mal je trouve vraiment toute la
spatialisation au niveau de mes
instruments ce soit au niveau des graves
au niveau des basses au niveau d'une
grosse caisse d'une caisse claire de
charleston en fait j'ai tout j'ai tout
et ça ce trouve ça vraiment bien donc ça
c'est vraiment super en plus de ça je
récupère des petits trucs que je
trouvais un peu moins bien définis
aujourd'hui nous retrouver plus de
certains morceaux là pour le coup je les
ai alors ça va être je vous dis que ça
plus de la finition la production c'est
souvent ce qui va se dire se perdre avec
des casques de qualité moindre on largue
des casques de mauvaise qualité
vous perdez ces petites finitions de
production on va retrouver un morceau si
vous voulez quelle espèce de
gloubiboulga sur des casques pas bonne
qualité et là vous ouvrez pas on est
dans une autre dimension et cette autre
dimension elle vraiment là il est
vraiment palpable on se rend vraiment
compte à laon pour ça il vous faut un
fichier de bonne qualité il vous faut un
abonnement sur teen dalle avec une
qualité master ou des choses comme ça où
là vraiment vous profitez quelque chose
qui est suffisamment intéressant qui
vous permettra de vous immerger cette
expérience audio donc ça c'est vraiment
génial et j'ai aimé et ce qui m'a
vraiment surpris c'est qu'on a spec qui
est très large vous partez dès hier des
seuils ce n'est pas de son sommes là
dessus on reste malgré tout sur des
drivers qui font pas non plus la taille
d'un haut parleur énorme et vous partez
sur des sons avec des vraiment des
basses ça ronronne
vous avez des bacs sont très présentes
et vous montez tout votre être vous
pousser jusqu'aux aigu sur la clarté
d'une cymbale sur la précision de nos
petits triangles vous récupérez ça et
vous récupérez rien la réverbération
dont on a vraiment cette clarté
on a ce sont qui est large et on le sent
vraiment l'expérience est là et pour
voir qu'on est sur quelque chose qui est
uniquement numérique et bien on retrouve
cet effet en tout cas haute définition
sur un casque numérique et sachons ça
vraiment bien et j'adore et rien que
pour ça c'est vraiment bien alors je ne
crache pas dans la soupe parce que une
fois de plus je trouve qu'on a plutôt
une très très bonne qualité avec un w h
nixon trois avec le codec ldlc où elle
date comme vous voulez mais là ils vous
emmènent l'expérience encore plus loin
chez apple
et ça c'est super vous savez apple et
vous mettre leurs puces là vous avez
leurs puces leurs puces à chocques vous
avez le plus h1 à gauche vous avez plus
à chaud à droite ce qui fait que c'est
plus sa chambre
tout piloter elle va tout gérer c'est
elle qui va faire un espèce de skylink
aux jo si je peux me permettre un petit
peu le petit peu le parallèle donc leçon
arrivants qualité plutôt pas trop mal en
bluetooth et la passe il vient de
maximiser et vous monte d'un coup
l'expérience elle est allée veulent et
il ya un travail derrière ya un
traitement qui est juste magnifique
cette puce à champ et vous permet
également d'avoir l'égalisation
adaptative c'est à dire qu'en fait votre
casque il est malin il intelligent il se
pose à votre oreille et quel que soit
votre morphologie va vous connaître et
ça c'est bien en fait il apprend à vous
découvrir et il va s'adapter
complètement à votre morphologie des
fois le son peut passer par là par là
par là donc lui ce qu'il va faire c'est
que vous avez trois micros à l'extérieur
sur chaque oreille et un micro à
l'intérieur donc oui il va venir
analyser le son qui à l'extérieur est
bien comparer avec le son intérieur il
va donc voir ce qui passe et vous
permettre de restituer le son le
meilleur soit complètement adapté pour
vous c'est ce qu'on appellera donc
l'égalisation à la pta type c'est pour
ça que vraiment remettre le tarif en
perspective 629 euros
les finitions les pus sachant
l'expérience alors après il ya un autre
qui est super intéressant c'est la
réduction de bruit parce qu'ici vous
avez un cas ce qu'on appelle à nc active
noise cancelling réduction de bruit
active
on est en français restons en français
et c'est super intéressant parce que
vous savez pour moi le champion de la
réduction brute à petit c'est lui c'est
sony wx1 prend clairement et depuis très
longtemps et là avec le airpod max on a
le veulent qu'ils claquent un cran au
dessus mais vraiment un cran au dessus
et pour preuve je fais des travaux en ce
moment à la maison ça on s'en fiche mais
du coup je me retrouve avec des bruits
de marteaux piqueurs à la maison pendant
cinq heures de suite 5 heures dessus des
bruits de marteaux piqueurs jeudi quelle
belle opportunité pour venir tester mon
casque et ceux qui voudraient sur et
airpod max est un cran au-dessus
réellement par rapport aux championnes
la réduction de bruit active
c'est-à-dire wmx m3 dixon cad s'il
voulait sensiblement la même chose ça va
assez surpris
vraiment je vous le cache pas je me suis
dit ça va être dur de faire mieux ils
font que le double dash nyx n 3 reste
quand même très très bien est excellent
et surtout beaucoup moins cher donc si
vous voulez un excellent casque à
réduction de bruit w/h mix m3 mais ils
s'aiment 4 pourquoi pas mais melix m3
surtout je vous recommande plus plus
plus plus aujourd'hui il a moins de 300
euros il est super intéressant là c'est
pareil on est quand même à 629 euros
donc ça paraît normal qu aussi à 629
euros
on s'attend d'abord une
fonction de bruit actif qu'il soit une
meilleure qualité après vous avez le
mode transparent alors le mode
transparence et lorsque vous prenez
votre casque vous êtes dans la rue vous
voulez entendre autour de vous pour
éviter vous faire écraser par un bus si
vous n'avez pas regardé
l'idée c'est vraiment ça en fait c'était
de pouvoir savoir ce qui se passe vous
pouvez venir l'activé très facilement à
travers d'un petit bouton vous êtes
bouton là vous appuyez mode transparent
vous répugnez réduction bruit active
alors après on a encore un autre mode
vous convient dans l'application
messages demandant quelques instants
cette transparence
je trouve plutôt bien je suis pas un
gros fan de mode transparent mais dont
tout ce que j'ai pu écouter c'est l'un
des meilleurs si ce n'est le meilleur
ce mode transparent vous permet vraiment
d'être au fait de tout ce qui passe
autour de vous avec un côté toujours un
petit peu médium de toute façon on est
sur des micro qui viennent réinjectés
dans un casque on n'a pas des micros du
studio pour me dire vous captez tout et
vous restituer de façon parfaitement
parfaite justement idéal mais malgré
tout ça marche quand même plutôt bien et
si vous souhaitez désactiver le côté
numérique
en tout cas au niveau de la réduction
proactive où tout est transparent et
bien vous pouvez le faire et votre
application vous avez dans vos
paramètres vous allez dans bluetooth
vous prenez votre épée repose max hop là
je me connecte acte agp affiche lui
connecter ici et là voyager différents
modes et là ça devient extrêmement
intéressant hop là on june déjà je peux
venir switcher manuellement au niveau de
mon contrôle du bruit
l'ag en mode transparent qui peut le
désactiver ou chômage la réduction de
bruit actif si je le souhaite un
labourier un truc et c'est marrant c'est
que là où il ya beaucoup de
constructeurs qui vous propose d'avoir
différents niveaux sur le vote
transparent sur la réduction de bruit
chez apple vous en a dit qu'un seul
c'est comme ça c'est comme ça c'est pas
autrement et surtout vous le voyez ici
vous des paramétrer votre bouton par
défaut vous est paramétré en réduction
de bruit active ou transparent c'est à
dire que lorsque vous appuyez sur le
bouton sur le côté
soit la réduction proactive sauvette en
mode transparent vous pouvez pas bien
coupés et bien vous suffit de venir
cliquez ici et là vous avez un switch
je veux bien structuré lâché en
transparent j'appuie là je suis en
désactivé et là je suis en réduction
d'objectif j'aurais pu sur transparent
et après vous avez ici les réglages au
niveau de la digital creux dans la
district ron c'est ça que vous retrouvez
ici et quand ils l'ont présentée j'ai
trouvé ça intéressant je sais pas si ça
va être bien honnêtement j'étais
vraiment dubitatif
parce que c'est exactement la même chose
que vous retrouvez ici sont tapés watch
c'est à dire une petite molette sait
vraiment si apple avec le wording
d'apple un les termes d'apple tenir la
digital crohn et 7digital croll est pas
écouté elle marche quand même vachement
bien
vous appuyez music play pause morceaux
suivants morceau précédent pour venir
accrocher décrocher vous montez le son
aussi envie retourner là c'est vraiment
très intuitif et ça marche vraiment très
très bien on peut choisir aussi pouvait
monter le volume en allant d'avant en
arrière
vous derrière en avant pas tous la même
logique donc j'ai trouvé aussi bien ça
s'adapte à tout le monde
alors après vous avez d'autres petites
fonctionnalités comme la détection
automatique de la tête lorsque vous
mettez le cadastre connecter l'iphone
automatiquement ou pallodio spatiale
pourrait venir activer ou désactiver
mais ici vous le savez chez apple les
produits vient de s'inscrire dans un
écosystème c'est apple c'est comme ça et
c'est intéressant alors cet écosystème
et les chocs et c'est pour moi un des
points forts de ce produit là je vous
explique exemple je travaille sur mon
mac est en train de faire un montage up
paf gelé là je suis en train de bosser
je fais mon petit montage tout va bien
je suis content c'est génial le
téléphone soit de la côte est alors
qu'est ce qui se passe déjà ça ne
l'affichent sur mon mac j'ai un coup de
fil je peux me dire décrocher mais je
peux décrocher directement à partir de
là et là je vais street celle sur mon
téléphone mais repose mâcon sud j'ai sur
mon téléphone et ça s'est super bien et
ensuite lorsque j'ai terminé
paf je peux retourner très facilement
dessus autre exemple le soir avec ma
chérie on se retrouve dans notre lit on
a chacun notre ipad
on est comme ça on aime bien les ipad et
les repose donc moi j'ai mon ipod max
avec mon ipad 2 8 ème génération est
elle est là c'est repose avec son ipad
pro et chacun à son ipad alors du coup
c'est bien parce que je me connecte
facilement jekel prendre le bouge offre
il se connecte directement à mon ipad ça
c'est bien maintenant il ya pas un peu
négatif c'est que lorsque je le prends
et qu' il est posé il va se mettre en
veille automatiquement au bout de cinq
minutes je crois et bien je le prends
qu'est ce qui va se passer
eh bien il va s'afficher sur son écran
elle a tjrs un tiers pose max et
l'attaquent appuyait tu te connectes
alors je trouve ça bien mais ça aussi
ses limites parce que elle sur son écran
alors qu'elle fait autre chose et
qu'elle a un autre ère post de connecter
eh bien ça vient lui offre une petite
pollution visuelle
le point qui intéresse en arrière c'est
que si par exemple on dit bastien et
chantal est assez rien tant que dans ma
chérie je prends mon casque je le mets
et qu'est ce qui va se passer est bien
là qu'à appuyer en même temps pour
accepter que l'airpod se connecte elle a
donc serpotta lg - pote à moi on est
connecté et on peut regarder le même
programme en même temps et c'est tout
l'intérêt de l'écosystème apple apple
marche très bien
grâce à son écosystème et sont
construits autour de ça et c'est pour ça
aujourd'hui que c'est une des marques
leaders premium grâce notamment aux
côtés écosystèmes les produits sont bien
bien aboutie de bonne facture mais
l'écosystème et une part très importante
chez apple
alors maintenant il ya un truc que
j'aime pas du tout mais vraiment pas du
tout c'est ça ça c'est ce qui s'appelle
la smart games et ça pour moi la smart
key c'est vraiment un truc je sais pas
j'ai pas compris alors en fait pour moi
apple là dessus a voulu nous faire un
accessoire de mode
en dix ans on fait un truc qui est joli
on est apple on est dans le disait
dans la mode j'ai l'impression d'avoir
un sac à main vraiment d'abord un sac à
main avec son petit arceaux que je
prends un peu baladé
mais la réalité et ce qui est
intéressant avec quelque chose comme ça
c'est lusage est en fait les âges pour
moi là dessus il est pas bon du tout je
ne trouve pas beau honnêtement quand
j'ai vu la présentation au début je me
suis dit c'est quoi ce truc c'est moche
c'est moche
franchement je trouve ça moche le casque
et je les aime bien ça comme ça c'est
moche ça c'est pratique c'est pas
particulièrement beau mais c'est
pratique pourquoi parce que lorsque je
prends mon casque eh bien voyez je peux
déjà le replier et ça c'est un point
positif
je le prends je le ferai je le met dans
un sac à dos et je pars en voyage
moi je pars souvent je partais souvent
j'espère revenir repartir tout quinze
jours en voyage et ça dans mon sac à dos
d'une cinquantaine de places et de 2 sur
tout ça ne sécurisent beaucoup d'entre
elles place remarquez vous me direz ça
prendra plus de place un petit peu moins
mais je me dis que si je prends un champ
claque ça bouge tout ça tape ça ne
dérange pas là je ferai pas la même
chose je suis pas à l'aise parce que la
réalité est bien c'est qu'en fait ici ça
protège rien c'est à dire si j'ai tapé
fort là je table sur mon casque
ça veut dire que si je le mets dans mon
sac et qu'un turc appuyé un peu trop
fort la venir habillé en tissu mesh je
te dire bémont arceaux je peux venir
tout abîmé et ça j'aime pas du tout on
dit lorsque je le mets mon cas se passe
en mode ultra basse consommation
d'énergie
ok super c'est un point de vue côté pas
beau c'est vraiment un côté très
personnel mais surtout c'est pas
pratique ça sert à rien je suis pas le
prendre dans la rue me balader comme ça
je vais dans un sac je ne protège pas il
est pas résistants davantage à la
poussière de cette manière là et ça pour
moi vraiment c'est une très mauvaise
idée
gemma connectique qui est apparente ici
alors que venir le recharger un côté
c'est sympa on dira c'est super il est
rechargé
mais en réalité ça voilà ça sert à rien
pour moi ça je proches dans l'aisne j'ai
déjà les dents d'ailleurs parce que je
trouve ça moche
autre point qui est super important
c'est l'autonomie alors ici vous avez un
casque une très très bonne autonomie on
est à 20 heures d'autonomie c'est ce que
nous donne apple c'est ce qu'on retrouve
sensiblement dans les cités alors j'ai
pas pris chrono à la main passe comme je
vous lis j'utilise le soir en fragmenté
je fais avec mon chrono à chaque fois
mais c'est à peu près ce que j'ai donc à
ce que là je les aime beaucoup je trouve
intéressante
il faut mettre en perspective par
rapport aux tarifs c'est un tarif qui
est très élevé c'est parfait pour toutes
les bourses
on est chez apple on est sur un produit
premium beaucoup de produits apple il
reste chat parce que premium mais la
qualité est là les finitions sont là
l'ingénierie et là les brevets
ont été posées le fait d'avoir ce
système là c'est très malin bon voila
moi j'aime bien
si vous voulez vraiment un cast
numérique premium avec un son
d'excellente qualité haute définition
numérique
ici vous pouvez y aller les yeux fermés
si vous avez plus de 600 euros à mettre
dans un casque ci-après vous avez moins
de 600 euros à mettre dans un casque wlh
mix m3 à moins de 300 euros c'est une
bombe atomique il marche super bien
donc en fait pour moi se produit ici
c'est la cerise sur le gâteau de
l'expérience apple si vous avez des
produits apple
si vous êtes 100% apple et si vous
voulez un produit premium extrêmement
prévient d'apple et bien les reposes mac
c'est la cerise sur le gâteau au niveau
d'expérience si maintenant vous voulez
un très bon produit apple pour goûter de
la musique de très bonne qualité et vous
n'avez pas pu tisser un euro à mettre
dessus bien vous achetez des repos ce
procès déjà cher c'est très très bien et
si vous voulez un casque d'excellente
qualité vous n'avez pas une fois de plus
petits sont euros m le bh mixel trois
mois ça j'aime beaucoup c'est une très
très belle découverte
j'étais très dubitatif au début quand le
tarif quand tu as tout cas ce prêt à
proposer apple a plus de 600 euros sur
ce produit là et au final eh bien je
comprends c'est pas des produits qui
vont vendre en énorme quantité comme on
va vendre des repose à moins de 200
euros alors il y aura des quantités
vendues parce que ça peut aller parce
que produit les tops mais on n'est moins
sûr le grand public c'est parce qu'ils
viennent chercher c'est parce qu'il vous
propose mais voilà moi j'aime beaucoup
a vous de me dire vous ce que vous en
pensez en bas en commentaire quand elle
retrouve très vite pour continuer à
parler tech et ça c'est super allez je
vous laisse j'ai la musique à écouter
des gros bisous beaucoup d'amour et des
sucreries pour vous ciao